joining me now is former secretary of
state mike pompeo uh secretary pompeo
always good to have you with us uh thank
you for being here great to be with you
martha um your thoughts on any of the
above what stands out to you
well you you began the conversation
around these issues in iran uh today we
had apparently uh iranian-backed
militias attacking our embassy in
baghdad um i've seen a little clip of
the video where
they're now threatening to kill
president trump and myself you have seen
that video and yet we have
negotiations we have negotiators sitting
at the table in vienna all right can you
can you tell me about that that video
what was your impression of it what's in
it
uh you know it's a look the reporting
says it was a video in a contest
but the iranian government itself the
could sports leaders themselves have
made clear
that they want vengeance against
president trump and me for
the strike that was taken against
general suleimani who was threatening
american lives we made the president
trump made the right decision i
recommended it to him we kept americans
safe we were always prepared to do that
today we've got negotiators sitting with
the iranians willing to give them money
resources power tools to continue to go
build out their terror network around
the world is an enormous mistake it puts
our great ally israel at risk it puts
our gulf state friends and saudi arabia
and the emirates at risk and bahrain and
kuwait all throughout the region and it
certainly puts america at risk as well i
can't figure out for the life of me why
we're sitting in vienna negotiating with
an iranian regime that is as we sit
there attacking our diplomats in baghdad
and threatening former senior american
officials
um
this is a sound bite from jensaki is is
this from just now you guys or
okay this one's from yesterday and this
is with regard to the jcpoa and the
trump administration come pulling out of
that agreement here's what she had to
say then
the fact that the former president
ripped at the nuclear deal uh meant that
iran's nuclear program was no longer in
a box and no longer had the most robust
inspection regime ever negotiated no
longer had the tight restrictions on
nuclear activity
what do you say to that sir
yeah she's living in a fantasy world
disconnected from the reality that was
the jcpoa it created a clear maybe a bit
delayed but a clear path for a nuclear
weapon not only that but a an entire
program of nuclear weapons martha that
the iranians would have had possession
of it's now seven years on since the
original signing that are almost seven
years it was signed in 2015 many of
those terms have expired and this
administration appears to be begging the
iranians to re-enter an agreement that
will run out in just a handful of years
it doesn't prevent the cataclysmic risk
associated with iran having a nuclear
weapon we were we were right to get out
and we had four more years i am
confident that ayatollah would have been
faced with an incredible decision
difficult decision about whether to
capitulate at risk to his continued
authority or to sign a deal with the
trump administration i think they would
have done that and we would have gotten
a deal that actually precluded iran from
enriching uranium in a way that
threatened israel and the united states
ned price talked about that he said you
know the trump administration kept
promising that there was going to be a
better agreement but it never happened
we never saw it
i wish we'd had another 365 days or
another four years martha i'm confident
that we had iran on its knees they had
less than 10
of the foreign exchange reserves left
for themselves we had denied them
millions of barrels of oil sales and
this this administration is already not
enforcing those sanctions iran is under
less threat the regime is under less
threat today than it was when we were
there we supported the iranian people
this administration has chosen to take a
different attack and is giving resources
to the kleptocrats and theocrats running
iran today so you heard john kirby from
the pentagon say that the situation with
russia is clearly not de-escalating
and
you have these suggestions by the
russian deputy foreign minister
that if they don't get what they want in
terms of nato backing down on their
borders they would consider putting
military infrastructure into venezuela
or cuba
what do you think
you know clearly not de-escalating uh
john's been at this a long time that's
pretty diplomatic language
uh yeah clearly not deal escalating when
vladimir putin believes that he can run
roughshod and continue to exert coercive
control martha you were talking about
this earlier this week he's doing this
in kazakhstan he did it in belarus
this administration let him close down
the pipelines that were in southeast
part of the united states and did almost
nothing in response this this kind of
weakness creates the situation well
they'll threaten to put real resources
right in right in our space right right
in venezuela right in cuba these are
real risks uh when you have deterrence
when you have leadership that's prepared
to protect american interest you can
prevent vladimir putin from even
thinking about heading down that path i
hope this administration will grab the
right end of the stick and begin to use
american power economic power diplomatic
power all the tools that we have
available building out alliances and
preventing vladimir putin from
continuing to use coercive authority to
gain power strength and the ability to
impact so many lives across the world
and threaten america too wendy sherman
who was also the lead negotiator or one
of the top negotiators in the jcpoa iran
agreement is the lead negotiator in the
discussions that are going on with
russia what do you think about the fact
that she said that the united states is
open to discussions on the placement of
missiles in europe
i suppose if you got the right
commitment from the russians and the
chinese about their nuclear programs and
their nuclear capabilities and their
strategic and operational missile
systems as well i suppose you could
imagine that
but miss sherman being there doesn't
give me much
much hope for that she not only was
involved in the jcpoa martha but she
negotiated a nuclear deal with the north
koreans that was eviscerated
immediately after it was entered into in
that administration that democrat
administration did nothing
we shouldn't let the russians dictate
our policy we should be about building
out a defensive and deterrence
capability in europe and around the
world that's how the trump
administration thought about this i hope
this administration will begin to think
about delivering real deterrence and
protecting america in the way that we
need to secretary pompeo thank you
always good to have you here sir thank
you martha thanks for being thanks for
letting me on today good to have you as
always hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else